after more than a year of coronavirus
restrictions italy is again welcoming
travelers from the u.s
before the pandemic venice was feeling
the impact of too many tourists
now it's treating the reopening as an
opportunity to balance the needs of
visitors
and its residents chris livesay visited
the city of canals to see how
it's coming back to life good morning
the pandemic was a double whammy for
italy's tourism industry first it was a
national
lockdown and then it was a ban on
american tourists
the biggest spenders here in venice but
now for the first time
since the pandemic americans are coming
back
a paradise on water
that the pandemic turned into a desert
but now direct flights from the u.s to
venice are finally landing again
tabitha waters and her family from
kentucky were among the first on board
what's the pandemic been like for you
i've lost a couple of family members to
it and my brother and
a good friend and i'm a nurse so
it's just been a really bad thing to get
used to and seeing the world finally
start to become normal again is
really good the feeling is mutual at
cafe florian
italy's oldest coffee house once on the
brink of bankruptcy during the pandemic
now americans like the waters family are
helping bring it back to life
my heart literally has not stopped
beating fast
like venice's newly reopened la fenice
opera house
named after the mythical phoenix the
city is
rising from the ashes jane demasto is an
environmental scientist
there's a lot of potential to make
life in the city a whole lot better
not just for us but for nature
and other organisms nature that filled
the void
ducks octopuses even dolphins in the
grand canal
but with restrictions now loosened those
days are over with tourists adding
up by the minute with such irresistible
beauty can you really blame them
of the venice hoteliers association says
the solution is clear
charge an entrance fee to the city
venice is not disneyland it's a living
city
but outside other sites in the world you
pay to get in
and let's limit the daily people limit
cruise ships as well
she says they not only dwarf the city
they're known
to crash into it just one of the
challenges to striking a
post coveted balance for both locals and
visitors alike
for cbs this morning chris lives say
venice